document ai helps organizations extract
and normalize information from
unstructured images
today we're announcing the general
availability of our first parsers for
document ai for identity
when we talk about processing identity
documents there are two classic problems
first
tons of id variants that are always
changing
and user uploads can be of poor image
quality bad lighting off-center and more
today we want to show you document ai
for identity in action we'll run through
a novel demo using a web application
built using the api that you can also
set up yourself from the linked source
code in the description below
first we'll adjust the settings of the
api that we'll call
you can select to process the data
either in the us or eu
more locations will be available over
time
then
select the id processor and in my case
i'll use us driver's license
for the input we provided the ability to
either choose from our sample documents
upload your own files or even take a
live photo from your webcam let's check
out how it works for the demo driver's
license i printed out
this activates my webcam i'm holding
this document off-center tilted and
maybe even too far too close
let's capture the image and go ahead and
process it
you'll notice that document ai captured
all the relevant fields even though the
photo wasn't perfectly aligned
this is a highly specialized
model-based processor
we were able to capture all of the
relevant fields such as the name ids
date and address
let's run another sample this is another
license from a different state
even though the format of the license is
different with different keys for the
relevant fields
thanks to document ai's response
schematization
i can expect to receive all the
important fields with a standard set of
keys
this makes it
much easier to pass on the data to a
database or for downstream processing
we can also capture the confidence score
for each of the extracted fields
you'll also be able to check out what
google normalize such as a date and
address
if the entire document or certain fields
do not meet your confidence score
thresholds you can configure a human
reviewer workflow
data can also be enriched through the
use of knowledge graph technology
if you want to take this a step further
you can use the id fraud detection
processor to gather confidence that the
document is indeed real
let's switch back to our first license
from colorado and test this out
there are three signals that this
processor will return
the first will predict whether the image
uploaded is a government-issued id
this is country agnostic
the second signal will look for
suspicious words on the card that
indicate whether a document is a demo or
a copy
here we clearly have a fake name and
address
the last will indicate whether the image
was manipulated in any way such as with
a third-party tool which was also
clearly done on the sample document
we could run through the same process
for other supported ids such as
passports try setting up the sample app
with the api or read more in the link to
the document ai for identity page today